Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the dome some of you might recognize this place
And I hope that you realize that when we're here we're about to do some crazy stuff usually with fire
And that's the case today. We're going to be trying an experiment that I am pretty excited about not too long ago
We showed you how to make a super cooled bath of acetone using some dry ice
And we can freeze stuff in it, and it was not quite as cold as liquid, nitrogen
But had a lot of sanity cools something interesting happened when I poured water into the supercooled acetone the water dispersed
But then very quickly throws into crystals, and as it sat in it for a while it turned into a slush
I took some that slush
lit it on fire on a brick and it burned pretty well if I was very interested in how I can touch it and
Simultaneously feel like my hand was freezing and on fire
I want to try making some snowballs out of that acetone ice slush and see what happens if I just light them on fire and
Throw them then while I was thinking about that
I thought maybe there are some other ways to make some fire snowballs, and I wanted to try some of those as well
So I called up my local ice rink, and I asked them if I could have some of the scraped off snow
That's created when they Zamboni the ice
They were gracious enough to let me take some of that snow
so I now have a cooler full of snow and a second cooler full of sand pre-packed snowballs and
The purpose of today's video is to see what kind of fluid we can pour on this snowball to get our best fireball
We'll use acetone isopropyl alcohol some lamp oil and even some gasoline on these snow walls to see which gives us the best
Fireball in addition to several different varieties of making the fire balls. I have a few different things
I'm going to try to launch them of course. I'll try just throwing them like a normal snowball
I've also got this dog toy designed for tennis balls But will use it for throwing the balls
And some of you may recognize our water balloon launcher that grant showed you how to build some time ago here
We've got some dry ice let's break some of this up fill our container around our Bowl
Then pour all of our acetone in and we should start to get a supercooled acetone bath
Even with good gloves on this stuff gets so cold so fast
There we go and our bucket here
It's got lots of holes drilled into it all the way around so that our acetone will easily
Get in but our dry ice will stay on the outside
there you go you can see the bubbles are starting to calm down
It means our acetone is starting to get nice and cold
Now the gloves I was wearing were good for installation
But they weren't
waterproof or
Acetone proof at all and so I've actually managed to squeeze a pair of the black gloves over the other gloves and now I should
Have insulated hands and ones that won't
Hold acetone as unweighting it on fire. That's just the combination I want
Let's try pouring some water into this bath. Let it cool down and see if we get that same slush. We got last time
Probably not even a little bit safe either
But I've got gloves on I've got long sleeves on I've got glasses on I'm kind of keeping myself held away
It's fine
Of course the water is able to get through the little holes in the plastic container
So we're just starting to get some slush surrounding all of the bucket and the dry ice and everything
But there is a lot more of it in the plastic bucket than out when we last made some of this acetone frost
Mixture it took a little while for it to really concentrate down and freeze all of the water in it
So let's just set it aside for a minute and try adding some of our fuels to our pre-made snowballs see how that works
We're already working on acetone, so let's try making an acetone soaked snowball
Not what I had in mind
I Didn't have quite the right tool for opening the lid the way you're supposed to the whole thing. Just popped right off
It should still pour out
Kind of that are probably splashed a little
Alright, we've got our snowball. Let's try and
Pour some acetone on it's not gonna pour very well, but looks
Like it's getting absorbed nice and into the snow. That's what we want
Now for the safe part lighting it on fire
Really not lighting very well, maybe we need more acetone
That's on fire only my gloves on fire the snowball is not
Successfully
melted a small portion of the snowball I
Don't think acetone is going to work very well, so let's move on to trying one of our other fuels
Next up we have our 91% isopropyl alcohol see if this works better than the acetone kind of have my doubts
Snowball just doesn't wick the fuel through itself enough to stay lit
It's almost like it's made of water or something well acetone didn't work and alcohol didn't work. Let's try lamp oil
No still nothing, huh
our lamp oil gets cold enough that it even solidified it starts to
Gel up a little bit the water and our supercooled acetone is now quite cold, and we've got a good slush
I'm gonna see if I can make that into a snowball light it on fire and chuck it
Squeeze a little bit of the acetone out
But not a lot because I think that will just make it not light so let's try that much see how this works
Just went out immediately all right, let's try it without squeezing it at all just get a big old scoop of acetone slush
Still not much this kind of goes out right away
I'm just gonna pour it out on the ground. This doesn't work as a snowball
Though I'm trying I won't think that he'd be able to feel anything through my gloves
Well, I've got one more idea. We have the whole acetone bath. It's really cold, but it is acetone
Well that just does not want to light
Are those three types of fuel didn't work, so we've had to upgrade to gasoline
and I'm a little nervous about doing this because it's gasoline but
You know for science, I guess
I think the whole rock is gonna light on fire whether or not the snowball does
Yep Drock lit on fire our snowball
Hey, that's on fire a little bit oh
It breaks open it catches on fire better. Oh yeah now, it's nicely ablaze as is my hand throwing
That one out my hand stayed lit
new strategy
I'll try part of the snowball in this pan of gasoline then bring it over here to the fire
To light it. See if this works
Yep
And I let my can of gas on fire
That's just gonna burn now now I know that the idea works
I got a snowball it stayed lit all the way to when it hit the wall
I just need to have the pan of not burning gasoline farther away from my source of fire
So I don't accidentally light it by holding a flaming snowball
live and learn
No snowball soaked in gasoline
Now a long ways away from our gasoline I
Don't know if it stays on fire all the way across very well, I'll try one that's considerably more soaked in gasoline
Which is a higher risk of lighting my hand on fire even more I?
Think it'll be worth it
Wow I got farther I think it got farther on fire
That was like on fire until it hit the wall, that's pretty good. All right. We've got our little dog toy thrower and
now I'm not as afraid of lighting my hand on fire it might melt this but
Let's try that
Ha it hit the wall still on fire fireball success
Now I brought this water balloon slash snowball launcher thinking that maybe I could try using it to launch some flaming snowballs
But since gasoline is the only thing that I can get to actually make these snowballs light on fire
I'm not gonna do that because I think when it launches. It was just sort of spray gasoline on fire
Everywhere, and that would probably include on me
That's just too dangerous for me to try right now
I will use it to just launch a snowball and you can see how well it works
But I'm not gonna try it while it's lit on fire
Flies beautifully
They have a few mixed results with our fire snowballs the acetone lamp oil and isopropyl alcohol
Weren't flammable enough to stay lit while soaking the fireball they would maybe light for a second and then just go out right away
gasoline gave us pretty good results with our snowballs
But it did have a tendency to light other things on fire at the same time so maybe not the best idea
But it did look really cool. That's the part. I like
Super cooling our water in the acetone gave us a snow that was a little bit flammable
But it didn't actually stay lit very well
He would light very briefly and then just go out and when he threw it it wasn't on fire anymore
Definitely our best result was from soaking the snow balls in the gasoline
I really preferred using the dog toy thrower to throw the snow balls because then my hands weren't lighting on fire as much and although
My gloves did a great job of keeping me from getting burned or even uncomfortably warm
It's obviously not a very safe thing to do
All in all this has been a fun experiment and although it didn't work out quite as well as I was hoping
We did get some really fun results
Thanks for joining us for this video and remember to come gear yourself up with products and merch at the king of random
Calm see you there
So it's just a little bit oh
Yeah, it does that put it out with snowballs
Snowballs are not an effective method of firefighting
Then you just gonna end up with me with hands on fire juggling snowballs
My hands are on fire
Hey guys
Thank you for your comments so many of you have really interesting
Suggestions for projects and experiments, and we love testing those out for you. I also wanted to say thank you for the great feedback
You're leaving for me and my team because we're all in this together, so thank you for being on our camp